Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Sebastian Betti
Gerolamo Saibene:
Elina ha creato l'atmosfera,
adesso è il turno
del professor Salvatore Natoli,
una persona così conosciuta che
non ha bisogno di presentazioni.
Dico soltanto che, attualmente,
insegna Filosofia Teoretica
presso l'Università degli Studi
di Milano-Bicocca
e Storia delle Idee
presso l'Università San Raffaele.
Professore...
(Applausi)
Salvatore Natoli: Abbiamo ascoltato
la sonata di Prokofiev,
e si potrebbe ben fare
un ragionamento esplicito
del rapporto tra la musica
e la filosofia, nel merito.
Ma comunque, almeno come
nesso analogico,
la musica è ritmo,
ed esiste anche un ritmo del pensiero.
Ed esiste anche un ritmo del tempo,
e quindi delle epoche.
Allora direi che, come domanda iniziale,
per chiarire cosa vuol dire
buon uso del mondo,
varrebbe la pena interrogarsi
su qual è il suono della nostra epoca,
in che epoca viviamo.
Qual è il ritmo della nostra epoca.
Anche perché tra le molte, tante
definizioni che ci sono della filosofia,
ce n'è una di Hegel
che dice che la filosofia
è la ripresa del proprio
tempo nel pensiero.
Quindi ritmo del pensiero,
ritmo del tempo.
Se io vi domandassi: qual è la parola
con cui voi definireste l'epoca?
Qual è la parola con cui voi riuscireste
a rendere il tono dell'epoca?
Ecco, pensate a questa domanda di fondo
(mentre io cercherò di mettere
a punto alcune questioni,
anche perché per il tempo
concesso a questa riflessione,
più che sviluppare argomenti
e accendere dei fuochi,
dei punti di rilevanza che poi
possono diventare occasione
per ognuno, di una riflessione)
qual è la musica del nostro tempo,
qual è la parola per definire l'epoca?
Si diceva: buon uso del mondo.
In questa mia breve riflessione,
intanto voglio chiarire
cosa vuol dire "buon uso del mondo"
e cosa vuol dire
usare bene il mondo oggi.
Capite che nell'espressione
"buon uso del mondo"
c'è un implicito, c'è un rinvio,
cioè del mondo si può fare
un cattivo uso.
Ecco allora il primo punto
per definire l'epoca:
stiamo facendo un buon uso del mondo,
o stiamo facendo
un cattivo uso del mondo?
E uso la parola "fare": stiamo facendo
un buon uso del mondo,
stiamo facendo un cattivo uso
del mondo, uso la parola "fare".
Che sembra chiara.
E però c'è un punto preliminare,
che io metto a fuoco
per chiarire un equivoco:
noi spesse volte confondiamo
l'agire con il fare.
Sono due termini che ci sembrano
sinonimi, pressoché equivalenti.
Ebbene, già qui c'è un'insidia,
e in fondo la matrice
dell'abuso del mondo,
proprio nella confusione,
o nella non distinzione,
tra il fare e l'agire.
In greco, "fare" si dice in tre modi:
praxis, téchne e poiesis,
che noi potremmo tradurre
con "azione", "produzione
o trasformazione" e "creazione".
Stiamo ai primi due termini:
praxis, téchne.
Agire, fare.
Ora, in greco la parola "praxis"
ha una radice, prag,
che vuol dire grossomodo questo:
"mi muovo, passo un confine"
e più esattamente "porto a compimento".
Quindi l'agire è dare al nostro movimento
una direzione, una destinazione,
cioè non c'è agire quando
ci si muove senza meta.
Tanto è vero che la parola
apràcticos, in greco,
non vuol dire "teorico" o "non pratico";
vuol dire "sbagliato", cioè
la prassi è la capacità di dare
al nostro movimento
nel mondo una direzione,
una meta, un senso.
Muoversi con sensatezza.
E il senso ultimo, la pienezza
di questo senso, è il bene e il male.
Infatti c'è un altro significato
della parola "prassi":
non solo "porto a compimento"
ma "mi occupo di", "mi appassiono".
Mettiamola in termini correnti:
nell'agire, ne va della mia vita.
Quanto, nelle nostre azioni, noi mettiamo
a tema questo "ne va della mia vita"?
Il fare non è orientato al senso,
non è orientato al bene e al male.
Il fare è orientato al risultato:
fatto bene, fatto male.
Al manufatto: “questo tavolo è
ben fatto”, “questo computer è ben fatto”.
Cosa vuol dire "ben fatto"?
[Che] corrisponde alle prestazioni
per cui è stato costruito,
che sono delle prestazioni
determinate, definite:
si fa questa cosa perché serve
per una certa prestazione.
Ma serve per la vita?
Ecco: il ben fatto, e il fatto male,
decidono della prestazione del manufatto,
non del senso e del
significato del manufatto.
Quindi, con lo sviluppo
dell'umanità nel tempo,
il fare, il produrre manufatti
ha prodotto grandi risultati:
Platone diceva che la téchne
è la scienza della vita:
l'uomo si è liberato dai bisogni,
producendo oggetti
si è liberato dai bisogni;
ma mano a mano che produceva oggetti,
più oggetti produceva,
meno capiva perché.
Non ne vedeva il senso, e quindi
si sono moltiplicati i risultati parziali,
ma il senso della vita in generale
è sparito, è rimasto sullo sfondo,
per cui noi ci muoviamo
senza sapere dove andiamo.
Il nostro fare è staccato dall'agire.
Pensiamo sempre al risultato,
ma mai al senso che questo ha
nell'intero della nostra vita.
E non ci domandiamo neanche
che senso ha la nostra vita:
siamo alienati nelle cose.
E alienati nelle cose, abbiamo perso
la direzione, non sappiamo dove andare.
E questo lo si registra
nella vita comune, corrente:
ci diamo tanto da fare,
ma al fondo c'è una scontentezza,
un'insensatezza, l'incapacità di
rispondere ai perché della vita.
E allora il fare non è un costruire
la vita, ma quasi un dimenticarsela,
perché non se ne è all'altezza,
perché un fatto è avere successo
in risultati parziali,
un altro è realizzare la pienezza
della propria esistenza.
Quindi il fare non è una conquista,
ma diventa una fuga.
E in questa fuga abusiamo del mondo.
Perché?
Perché non è l'esercizio
della nostra libertà,
che ci interessa,
ma confondiamo la libertà
con la mobilità.
C'è un film tedesco, "Falsche Bewegung",
falso movimento:
ci muoviamo, ci muoviamo,
ma senza nessuna destinazione.
Però, siccome ci muoviamo,
crediamo di essere liberi,
ma quanto noi siamo autori
del nostro movimento?
Perché l'azione ha un titolare, ha un fine
e all'origine c'è una decisione.
Nelle prestazioni, nei lavori,
nelle cose che facciamo,
quanto noi decidiamo?
Quanto non ci sono imposti?
Quanto non sono momenti
di una routine anonima,
Rispetto a cui c'è solo vacanza,
ma non senso?
Poi non sappiamo neanche
come riempire le vacanze,
e allora abbiamo bisogno
di prontuari, schemi.
Quanto decidiamo,
e quanto invece siamo condotti
da un'inerzia del fare,
e quindi confondiamo
la mobilità con l'attività?
Il risultato è un sentimento
di delusione
e spesse volte di stress.
E di uso del mondo che non valorizza
il mondo e le cose,
ma si appropria di cose.
L'elemento della appropriazione
prevale su quello della fruizione,
perché nel fruire delle cose
bisogna essere attenti
alle proprietà delle cose.
Nell'appropriazione, invece,
non c'è la fruizione,
ma c'è tutt'al più il consumo
e la dimensione nostra
è l'ossessività del consumo.
Oggi noi non abbiamo più
un'esperienza della libertà
come "decisione per",
ma abbiamo un'esperienza della libertà
come accesso ai beni.
L'esperienza della libertà è data
dalla nostra capacità di acquistare,
non dalla nostra capacità di decidere.
E mai come nell'acquisto
siamo eterodiretti.
La pubblicità, la performance:
siamo costantemente sottoposti
che ci porta sempre più fuori di noi.
E questo lo vediamo
anche nell'educazione:
quanto i bambini sono riempiti, assistiti
e poi sostanzialmente
non si sanno governare,
anzi l'unico modo per metterli
a tacere è riempirli,
rendendoli sempre più
incapaci di decisione
e sempre più sottomessi al consumo,
e quindi tendenzialmente perversi.
La decisione nasce dal fatto
che dinanzi all'offerta delle cose
ci si tira indietro, le si giudica
e si scelgono quelle
che servono di più
per la mia realizzazione.
Ma per capire questo, le cose che
servono di più alla mia realizzazione,
io devo capire quello che sono,
quello che posso fare,
qual è la mia vocazione,
qual è la mia disponibilità.
Devo conoscermi,
e questo esige riflessione.
L'avete visto, nella musica:
è tempo, è ritmo, è sospensione,
la musica gioca col silenzio,
quando è continua non è musica,
ma è rumore e noi oggi
siamo nella società del rumore,
non della musica, o perlomeno
rischiamo di esserlo,
perché non sempre è così.
Perché tutto questo che io
sto presentando come rischio
è anche una grande
ampiezza di opportunità,
solo che il soggetto
sia titolare di questo,
non sia sottoposto a un movimento
passivo, ad uno sfruttamento,
perché l'uso del mondo è lo sfruttamento,
e noi siamo dinanzi
a un doppio sfruttamento:
sfruttiamo il mondo
senza comprenderne il valore,
e sfruttiamo noi stessi in quanto
macchina di consumo senza destinazione.
Per dirla con Platone, siamo fatti
per mangiare ed evacuare,
mangiare ed evacuare,
mangiare ed evacuare e mai essere.
Questo suppone distacco, un momento
di sospensione e riflessione:
chi sono io?
Perché questo, per me?
Abbiamo perso la dimensione
autorevole della selezione del bene,
noi siamo incalzati e quindi la libertà
non come titolarità di una decisione,
ma la libertà come accesso al consumo
e infatti nella vita pratica
ci si sente meno liberi se
si riduce l'accesso al consumo,
non se si è capaci di scelta:
e allora si abusa del mondo
e lo si impoverisce.
Ci si appropria del mondo
senza saperlo usare,
perché per saperlo usare
bisogna, necessariamente,
essere attenti alle cose.
Non divorarle, ma coltivarle.
Aristotele, quando parlava di politica
e soprattutto di economia,
aveva formulato un tema, una questione
relativa proprio alla musica,
all'auletica (aulòs è il flauto),
e si domandava:
a chi bisogna dare un flauto?
Bisogna darlo a chi non ce l'ha?
Bisogna darlo a chi l'ha costruito?
Bisogna darlo a chi lo sa suonare?
Qui c'è un problema di etica,
di politica e di economia:
come distribuiamo una risorsa scarsa,
visto che stiamo parlando
di uso del mondo?
Allora alcuni, con buone ragioni,
dicevano, possono dire,
(tra l'altro questa dimensione è ripresa
da un grande economista
contemporaneo, Amartya Sen -
suo il "Saggio sulla giustizia",
Premio Nobel per l'Economia -
che si rifà molto ad Aristotele):
Allora, a chi lo diamo?
Lo diamo a chi non ce l'ha?
Ci sono tanti che hanno tanti giocattoli:
facciamo uguaglianza,
diamolo a chi non ce l'ha.
Un buon argomento: è un argomento
di giustizia distributiva,
un argomento egualitario.
Però un altro si alza e dice:
se lo diamo a chi non ce l'ha,
lo togliamo a chi l'ha costruito.
Ora, ognuno è padrone del suo lavoro,
e se è padrone del suo lavoro,
deve trattenere o vendere quello
che è suo, non possiamo toglierglielo.
Quindi l'ha costruito,
ma anche se non lo sa suonare,
glielo dobbiamo lasciare.
Questa è la posizione dei liberali
assoluti, di liberalismo puro:
si è padroni di ciò che si fa.
Poi altri possono dire:
sì, è vero, però se lo diamo
a chi non ce l'ha,
glielo diamo come
un qualsiasi giocattolo...
... sì, probabilmente potrà imparare,
visto che ce l'ha,
a suonare il flauto,
ma a che punto arriverà?
Certamente imparerà,
non è male darglielo.
Però è il modo più opportuno
di distribuirlo?
E magari, chi l'ha fatto non lo sa
suonare, o non gli interessa suonarlo.
Allora dobbiamo darlo a chi lo sa suonare,
perché questo farà due cose insieme:
realizzerà una sua capacità,
e nello stesso tempo
soddisferà gli ascoltatori:
il pianoforte, se noi l'avessimo dato
in mano a chi non lo sapeva suonare,
avrebbe strimpellato
e ci avrebbe infastidito.
Allora lo diamo a chi lo sa suonare
E quindi trarrà soddisfazione lui
e trarranno soddisfazione
quelli che l'ascoltano.
Questo è l'argomento degli utilitaristi.
Tutti hanno buone ragioni,
chi l'uno chi l'altro,
ma Aristotele la risolve così:
bisogna darlo a chi lo sa suonare,
ma non perché è meritevole
in quanto capace,
e non perché dà soddisfazione
a coloro che lo ascoltano,
ma perché la natura del flauto,
in quanto oggetto,
è fatta per essere suonato bene.
Il rispetto delle cose,
anche delle cose materiali:
si fa buon uso del mondo
se si ha rispetto delle cose,
perché soltanto avendo rispetto
delle cose, di tutte le cose,
si valorizzano le possibilità
immanenti ad esse.
Allora questo che cosa comporta?
Comporta attenzione, esercizio,
comporta conoscere le latenze
e le possibilità che una cosa ha,
liberare nella cosa
tutte le sue possibilità.
Ma chi ha visto "I prigioni" di
Michelangelo non ha bisogno di filosofia:
li vede che escono dalla pietra,
e Michelangelo diceva:
ma sono dentro, sono dentro alla pietra,
non sono io che ce li ho messi, li tiro
[solo] fuori, li vedo nella pietra,
li vedo nella venatura del marmo.
Questo vuol dire fare buon uso del mondo.
Ma questo cosa suppone, il possesso? No.
Suppone il dono, la dedizione alla cosa.
E già nella Bibbia questo era detto:
"e lo pose nel Paradiso Terrestre
perché lo custodisse".
Non perché lo sfruttasse.
È la custodia.
Quindi il fare che
sa amministrare è l'agire;
il fare che non sa amministrare,
non sa decidere
e non sa apprezzare distrugge il mondo.
Noi oggi, invece, siamo in una società
dove siamo costantemente
provocati a consumare.
Anche negli oggetti:
rinnovare, rinnovare. Buttare.
Cosa si conserva? Ma se nulla
si conserva, nulla è prezioso!
E questo non lo si fa
con gli oggetti soltanto;
lo si fa con gli uomini,
lo si fa con le relazioni umane,
lo si fa nei rapporti affettivi,
lo si fa nei legami:
tutti i legami imprigionano,
rompiamo i legami!
E alla fine che cosa succede?
Grandi solitudini.
Mangiamo gli altri, divoriamo gli altri,
ma quando noi siamo impotenti
e soli, chi ci aiuterà?
Ecco: l'incapacità di costruire
il legame e il rispetto con le cose.
Quindi noi ci troviamo
in un mondo abusato,
perché la prepotenza prevale sull'azione.
La provocazione sulla decisione.
E quindi che cosa?
Correre, correre, correre, correre,
correre - per arrivare dove?
Quindi noi viviamo in una società
complessivamente drogata.
E non la droga "droga":
tutto diventa droga,
se si patisce
e ad esso ci si asserve,
tutto diventa droga se si subisce.
Ma come dicevano gli antichi,
anche i veleni noi possiamo usare
se siamo padroni di noi stessi,
perché li sappiamo ponderare.
Quindi la perversione
non nasce dalla cosa,
nasce dalla incapacità di decidere
per noi su di essa.
Quindi il problema non è
degli oggetti, buoni o cattivi;
il problema è delle giuste relazioni
tra soggetti, cose, mondo, altri.
Ritrovare la misura giusta,
la concordanza, il ritmo, l'accordo,
che è il significato vero e proprio
della parola "temperanza" -
di cui noi abbiamo perso il significato:
la stiamo confondendo con la
repressione del desiderio, la temperanza.
La stiamo confondendo
con la rinuncia, la temperanza;
quando la temperanza
ha un'origine musicale:
Bach, il clavicembalo ben temperato,
passare da una tonalità
all'altra senza stonare,
trovando sempre il ritmo, la misura,
l'intonazione, il governo.
Il governo di sé e delle
relazioni con gli altri.
Governo sì, governo di sé,
perché se noi non moduliamo
il nostro desiderio,
il desiderio diventa voglia sfrenata
che mangia il mondo;
ma se noi divoriamo il mondo,
divoriamo le condizioni stesse
della nostra esistenza.
Per dirla con Nietzsche,
"cresce il deserto",
e noi lo stiamo desertificando.
La temperanza è l'accordo
di tre dimensioni:
io-mondo-altri, altri-io-mondo,
in una circolarità perfetta,
in questo equilibrio.
E questo esige rispetto e riconoscimento:
non a caso Kant, che parla
di buon uso del mondo,
mette al centro della sua riflessione
filosofica il rispetto dell'altro.
Che poi è la parola vera, grande,
del significato di pietà;
perché la pietà non è
quel sentimento patetico,
non è la lacrima, non è
neanche la compassione.
Perché come già aveva
dimostrato la filosofia antica,
e un grande economista come Adam Smith,
quando parla della simpatia - noi
abbiamo simpatia degli altri... quando?
C'è una naturale simpatia:
se io vedo che qualcuno sta male,
tendo naturalmente ad aiutarlo,
ma perché lo faccio?
Lo faccio per dedizione, oppure
perché economicamente immagino
che se mi trovassi in quella situazione
anch'io vorrei essere aiutato?
Nel fondo di quella compassione
c'è un larvato egoismo:
lo aiuto per essere aiutato,
c'è una logica dello scambio.
C'è anche la spontaneità,
ma dobbiamo andare a vedere
dov'è la spontaneità, e perché c'è.
E lui fa un argomento
per prova contraria e dice:
se io vedo una situazione di dolore,
qualcuno in una situazione di dolore,
quindi una situazione brutta, terribile,
allora io tendo a identificarmi con lui,
cioè lo vorrei tirar fuori
da quella situazione,
perché ci potrei essere io;
ma se io vedo qualcuno
in una situazione di successo,
dove ambisco a quella posizione,
allora io sono competitore dell'altro,
cioè laddove la posizione è di disagio,
io sono simpatetico con il disagiato;
ma dove la situazione sia di successo,
io sono simpatetico con la situazione,
ma non sono simpatetico col vincitore,
perché è un mio competitore.
Ecco, il rispetto no.
Il rispetto è invece il riconoscimento
incondizionato dell'altro.
E se questo è reciproco,
la ricchezza è infinita.
Perché in questa situazione,
se tutti si sentono creditori nei
confronti degli altri, tutti ricevono.
Se tutti pretendono, l'uno toglie
all'altro irreversibilmente,
e in questa competizione
si mangia il mondo,
e quando si mangia il mondo
ci troviamo nel deserto.
Ecco, allora buon uso del mondo
vuol dire diventare
titolari delle proprie azioni.
Rispettosi delle cose e degli uomini,
cercando di valorizzare in tutto
le potenze latenti in tutto.
E può essere il flauto, può essere
la relazione con un altro.
Questo è il concetto vero di merito,
e Aristotele l'ha chiarito:
il concetto vero di merito
è permettere ad ognuno
di liberare al massimo
le sue possibilità.
È la fioritura dell'ente,
questo è il merito.
E se il merito è questo, non può essere
deciso dalle prestazioni sociali,
perché le prestazioni sociali
non guardano alla fioritura,
alla possibilità dell'altro;
le prestazioni sociali
rendono meritevole
ciò che arricchisce la macchina,
ed espellono quello
che non arricchisce la macchina.
E quindi molte volte,
per diventare meritevoli,
bisogna rinunciare
alle proprie stesse qualità.
Come il giovane della famiglia borghese
dei Buddenbrock,
che diventa marginale
perché ama suonare il violoncello,
in una società che tende alla ricchezza
e al profitto della borghesia.
Come siamo fatti tutti?
Questo è il buon uso del mondo,
e per farlo è necessario
prendere distanza, riflessione.
La riflessione è il tornare su di sé,
e solo nella riflessione
c'è la distinzione, perché
cos'è il contrario della riflessione?
È l'identificazione.
Appiattirsi con l'altro,
cosalizzarsi nella cosa.
Solo se io ho distanza mi avvicino,
altrimenti perdo la mia stessa identità.
[C'è] L'appiattimento nel presente.
Ecco perché è difficile
rispondere alla domanda:
qual è la parola che troveresti
per il presente?
Perché essendo appiattito su di esso,
non lo riconosci e non ti riconosci.
Allora bisogna avere
la capacità di sottrazione,
quell'esercizio che consigliavano
gli epicurei, l'ascesi -
anche questa parola persa,
confusa:
rinuncia, ascesi... no,
nel mondo greco gli àsketai erano
gli atleti, e in particolare i pugili.
L'ascesi era l'esercizio
per potenziare le proprie possibilità,
e ci voleva applicazione.
Quindi non rinuncia ma potenziamento,
questa è l'ascesi.
Allora consigliava Epicuro:
ogni giorno fate questo esercizio
(non lo dobbiamo ripetere
allo stesso modo, ma guadagnarne l'idea)
ogni giorno fate questo esercizio:
diminuite i vostri piaceri,
del cibo, del sesso,
anche della musica.
Diminuiteli.
Ma diminuiteli per vedere,
per raggiungere quel punto
in cui vi accorgete che
non ne potete fare più a meno.
A questo punto, potrete distinguere
tra il necessario e il voluttuario,
e quando sceglierete, sceglierete
con capacità di distinzione,
perché se voi inseguite il piacere,
l'esito naturale sarà la perversione:
di più, sempre di più, sempre di più.
E sviluppando, peraltro,
solo una parte di noi stessi,
perché nella ricerca del piacere
si cercano i piaceri più facili.
Perché quei piaceri
che devono essere conquistati
perdono di prestigio
nei confronti dei più facili:
per suonare come ha suonato questa ragazza
bisogna dedicarsi,
e poi viene un grande suono;
ma per stordirsi nelle discoteche,
per stordirsi con un martello pneumatico,
non ci vuole molta intelligenza,
anzi quella che c'è svanisce.
Ma non solo l'intelligenza,
svanisce anche la sensibilità;
prendete questi animali da discoteca,
fate sentire loro il canto di un grillo,
e vedete se lo percepiscono.
Fate ascoltare loro il vento tra
le foglie, e vedete se lo percepiscono.
Non sanno usare il mondo,
solo distruggerlo.
Un'ascesi strategica, quindi:
non una rinuncia,
ma la distanza per scegliere,
per creare armonia.
E concluderò questo mio ragionamento
proprio con un testo di Platone.
Platone diceva che per fare bene filosofia
bisogna prima studiare
la musica (l'armonia sensibile);
poi la matematica
(l'armonia intellegibile)
e poi la filosofia
(l'armonia delle sfere).
E rivolgendosi a Callicle, che era invece
un depredatore del mondo, gli dice:
"E i sapienti dicono, Callicle,
che cielo e terra, dèi e uomini,
sono tenuti insieme
dalla comunanza, dall'amicizia,
dalla temperanza e dalla giustizia.
Ed è proprio per tale ragione, amico,
che essi chiamano
questo intero universo "cosmo".
Cosmo ha la radice "kens"
che è la stessa di "cosmesi".
Il cosmo è il ben ordinato mondo,
è l'ornato della Natura.
Cosmo-cosmesi che tiene insieme
l'intero Universo,
ossia ordine e non invece
disordine, dissolutezza.
Ora mi sembra che tu
non ponga mente a queste cose,
pur essendo tanto sapiente.
E mi sembra che ti sia sfuggito
che l'uguaglianza geometrica
ha un gran potere tra gli dèi.
Geometrica, non aritmetica,
perché non siamo numericamente uguali,
ma siamo diversi e quindi
deve essere acquisito,
dato e distribuito in proporzione.
L'eguaglianza è distribuzione
di opportunità,
non omologazione in basso
e abbattimento delle qualità.
E quindi l'armonia
è proporzione anche, appunto,
tra ciò che nell'ente
è predisposto alla sua fioritura.
L'eguaglianza geometrica è in gran potere
tra gli dèi e tra gli uomini.
Tu credi invece che si debba
perseguire l'eccesso,
infatti trascuri la geometria".
Io credo che questa sera, probabilmente,
un po' di geometria l'abbiamo fatta.
E la musica è diventata
la buona premessa, credo,
per una buona filosofia.
(Applausi)
Gerolamo Saibene: Grazie.
Per finire, Elina,
che vive in Italia da due anni,
aveva piacere di dare un contributo
al 150° anniversario
dell'Unità d'Italia, a suo modo.
Elina?
(Applausi)
(Musica)
G. Saibene: Grazie Elina Cherchesova,
grazie professore Natoli.
(Applausi)
Adesso vi spiego perché l'abbiamo fatto
alle 19, questo piccolo evento:
perché abbiamo l'ambizione che andando
tutti a cena, come immagino farete,
magari le emozioni che avete provato
e i pensieri che avete ascoltato
possano diventare, una volta tanto,
spunto per una conversazione
a tavola. (Risate)
Vi ringrazio per la partecipazione,
vi ringrazio da parte di Sim-patia
e vi do appuntamento, per chi vorrà,
a sabato 5 novembre
al Politecnico di Milano
per la terza edizione di TEDxLakeComo.
Grazie e buona serata!
(Applausi)